the easy highway has all these signs and
directions how to get somewhere and you
have to first be uncomfortable with how
you feel about yourself there's nothing
I'd rather do than work a 15-hour day
you're self aware you know you and I
always have this why I shoveled snow and
did lemonade and I washed cars as a
seven-year-old all day long
all right listen and listen well because
no truer words are ever gonna be spoken
wanna be happy build our life not just a
business
so love you and I believe in life for
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
improve yourself and live a better life
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one face the real you with David Goggins
a lot of people can live with themselves
look in the mirror and say I'm okay with
being afraid I'm okay with going on
that's easy highway over here the easy
highway has all these signs and
directions how to get somewhere and you
have to first be uncomfortable with how
you feel about yourself with that voice
that allow most like to run away from we
all have it we all have that voice that
say hey man you know you're you're kind
of whimpering out right now you kind of
be a little punk right now but I would
say okay that's okay it's okay to tell
you little white lies to ourselves so
you first have to face the real you the
real me is David Goggins the real me is
a guy looking at you right now saying I
don't want to be on this show right now
because I used to stutter as a kid and
I'm afraid of that I'm afraid that here
in a second I'm gonna start stammering a
stutter and the whole world is gonna
know that I have all these issues but
that's when I see right now okay Goggins
you got to go on this show that's
Goggins Goggins is saying okay David
Goggins you're a punk
life made you this way we can't live
like this we can't live in fear we can't
live in judgment we can't be afraid of
with the people right now looking at me
saying about me we cannot be afraid of
that
that's Goggins Goggins saying all of you
who don't like me who don't want to in
that person then it comes in but you
have to be David Goggin to say man I'm
afraid of this I'm up here life made me
this way here I stutter I have these
issues with reading and writing and I'm
fat and I'm insecure you have to face
that in that dark room in that dark room
is who you are
but in that dark
room is where you have to create another
human being that walks out of that dark
room to face who you are that's the only
way you're gonna get over all those
things you have to create someone else
not like you have two different
personalities it is you but you have to
find strength in that visualization of
almost me cracking out Goggins like
almost like that Superman cape like I'm
coming out a different person a person
that doesn't give up about anything who
doesn't care about being judged who
knows I'm weak who knows I'm afraid
who says whatever you think about me
take it whatever I'm here that's
guidance in the dark room you face
yourself you realize you want to be
better you realize you don't want to be
this weak insecure person in the world
who has all these problems that we all
have we all have souls to me is a great
platform to tell you who we want to be
now who we are so that's where that
darkroom is rule number two have
self-awareness with Gary Vaynerchuk
outside of spending time with my inner
family and closest friends and outside
of garage selling and watching the Jets
there's nothing I'd rather do than work
a 15-hour day yourself where you know
you and I always have this why I
shoveled snow and did lemonade and I
washed cars as a seven-year-old all day
long on August 9th because it's what I
like and I'm not gonna judge somebody
who wants to work 9:00 to 5:00 be on 13
softball teams and play video games all
day and make 42k year if she and he are
pumped as they're equal to me because I
know a bunch of miserable billionaires
and I know a lot of happy 55 ka years
and everything in between so here's my
thing if you listen carefully I'm only
spitting two core things you'll be
self-aware and you make yourself happy
and don't let anything other variables
you are just the macro variables and -
this is what makes me happy a lot of
people are spinning their ideology on
other people especially after they've
already accomplished something so you
talk patience - right that people should
be patient in in the pursuit of their
goals at what point does patient just
become delusion
a lot of times oh so what are the hacks
or the tips that you for them to be
self-aware to know when to just why
don't when is patience just right well
if you've been doing the same thing for
seven years and nothing good has
happened you're delusional
let's start there that's a test I
believe in a if there's been no progress
in your rap career or in your art or
your video blog and you've been doing it
every day for seven years as hard as you
can and nothing has happened
the market has spoken that's one way now
is that four years is that two years do
people jump off like you need to see
some level of progress to keep you
having blood in the water to get you
going
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below you can outwork anybody how bad as
they are in a success world please
understand that success is happiness not
net dollars in so many times I get the
question how do I prevent failure and
I'd love for you to spend that same
energy going how could I ensure that I
soar
rule number three break your thinking
patterns with Tim Ferriss what if I did
the opposite for 48 hours this is a
question I asked myself when I had my
first job out of college I was talking
about suffering I mean my desk was in
fire exit it was completely illegal
you know slept under the desk the whole
nine yards and don't regret a minute of
it but I was a Technical Sales guy
outbound sales guys we had inside sales
outside sales and my job was to close
deals with CTOs and CEOs for
multi-million dollar data storage
systems at that point storage area
networks the fiber channel and but I
realized at one point was that all of
the seasoned sales guys who were doing
far better than I was doing we're making
phone calls between nine and five those
were the office hours and I said well
I'm clearly not doing an effective job
mimicking them what if I did the
opposite for 48 hours it's a very
recoverable experiment but if it doesn't
work then I can always go back to what I
was doing doing the opposite met making
my calls between well
just say 6:30 and 8:30 and then 5:30 to
7:00 7:30 and it was just a hypothesis
maybe I can get a hold of the people I
need to get a hold of more effectively
when the gatekeepers aren't there and
that's exactly what happened and I
started booking more meetings and
closing more deals than than the
majority of the guys in the company and
it was just from asking that question
what I thought did the opposite for 48
hours and you can apply that to many
many things some of the others would be
well this is one I asked in 2004 yep if
I had a gun against my head and could
only work two hours per week what would
I do
I I know it's impossible what would I do
and that type of ludicrous question was
necessary to break my thinking patterns
and test stress test my own assumptions
of what was possible and you find that
that is a learner Buhl's Gill rule
number four use affirmations with Lisa
Nichols Christie talked about
affirmations abundant thinkers
understand the power of I am anything
after the word I am is true to your
unconscious mind Michael anything
anything after I am anything anything
after I am even if you just you know
it's not true your conscious mind will
believe it anything after I am so the
use of affirmations is very intentional
and very consistent I was diagnosed as
clinically depressed and 2001 1998 I'm
sorry I was diagnosed as clinically
depressed me it didn't make sense I had
been in a relationship I was engaged to
get married and my fiancee who I did not
know at the time was bipolar and he
stopped taking his medicines and under
the belief system that love can cure
anything and so I ended up being picked
up and thrown three feet across the room
and I end up being children Todd passed
out and once I got out of that
relationship
I just was different it was different so
my mom insisted that I go to the doctor
I went to the doctor and I sat on the
table and she checked me and talked to
me and came back in with a prescription
and she said ELISA you're clinically
depressed and I felt like I heard
Charlie Brown's parents talking like wah
wah want want want clinically depressed
at least don't that make sense in that
same sentence and she'd get handed me a
prescription and I read the description
it had my name on it and it said Prozac
I thought they don't make sense Lisa
Nichols Pro they don't make sense and I
said do you mean I'm sad she said very
very sad I said can I try something and
I'm not I'm not recommending you guys if
you're on medication you stop taking
meds
please don't do that I asked my doctor
she agreed I said do you mind if I try
something before I take this she goes
yes but I need to see you back in 30
days if you're in the same condition I
need us to try it this medicine I said
okay I could do that so I went home and
every day I got in the mirror and I
drilled I am every day cuz I realize I
have forgotten who I was I just forgot
it's just and it was okay to forget I
just forgot so every day every day for
25 minutes I just went over the IMS
every day I am I am I am and that I
parent that with I forgive you for then
i parallel that when I commit to you
Lisa every single day I went back in 30
days and I'm talking to her and I'm on
fire she's just looking at me I'm just
talking talking twisted her head again
and I'm just talking talking she says
wait I gotta stop you I said why she
goes what are you taking and can I have
some I was like I'm taking some of me
and so the power of I am the power of I
am can pull you through the darkest
moment the power of I am I knew number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is put in the work with Tom
bill you all right listen and listen
well because no truer words are ever
gonna be spoken
you can do anything you want without
limitation whatever it is that you
decide you want to make come true in
your life you can do that it is gonna
take an inhuman amount of work you're
gonna have to be prepared to break
yourself in half you are going to have
to learn more than anyone has ever
learned you can have to push yourself
harder than anyone has ever asked you to
push yourself before you're gonna go way
beyond your breaking point you're gonna
run and tell you vomit you're gonna
study until you fall asleep you're going
to push and push and push and then
you're gonna push some more and when you
hit the limit you're gonna push again
beyond that you're gonna force yourself
into an adaptation response and why
because it's Malcolm X said the future
belongs to those who prepare for it
today so if you don't put the work in
today if you don't do the unending
back-breaking work of developing
yourself into something greater the
world is gonna pass you by the people
that are going to own it are going to be
the ones that did
and the one promise that I can make you
right now is that somebody somebody out
there is out working somebody right now
is doing the things that I'm saying
somebody right now is doing the work of
failing and getting up and getting
better and pushing themselves and
triggering that glorious adaptation
response that makes humans the apex
predator someone right now they're
putting in that work and if you don't
the future is going to belong to them
and as Martin Luther King jr. said you
can't climb than one if you can't run
then walk if you can't walk then crawl
but whatever you do you have to keep
moving forward it's not okay to make
excuses it's not gonna slow people down
it's not okay
to ask the world to stop so that you can
step out front it's not okay to expect a
little of yourself and
and great rewards the only thing that's
okay is to be in line with the way that
the world really works and if you want
to be great you've got to become capable
and greatness you've got to develop your
skills that you've got to take what you
have now and if that's crawling and
crawl but you drag yourself ever forward
to a vision of yourself that is so clear
and so specific that
could knock you off your path because
you my friends know exactly where you're
going you're willing to pay whatever
price it takes to get there and no
matter what anybody says no matter how
many hecklers come for you no matter how
many people try to fill dirt on you try
to stop you try to knock you down no
matter how many people come for you at
night while you sleep
and you will keep pushing forward and
you will get better every day and no
matter how many times people chop at you
knock you off the bathroom yet
you'll crawl soon you can walk you
my friends is the only path forward so
if you want in the future that makes you
happy if you want a warm that you're
excited about and get your ass out there
and earn it now I have a special bonus
clip from Edie my lad on how to learn to
listen that I think you can enjoy but
before that is time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go question number one where do you
just need to put in the work number two
what's an affirmation you can tell
yourself every morning for the next week
and number three what's the consistent
thinking pattern that you need to break
and if you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
if it is we do something afterwards give
me a hash tag believe in the comments to
make that promise to yourself then go
keep it and one of the things we've not
covered that is such a critical part of
communication and maybe more important
even what you say is your ability to
listen to people it's a huge part of
communication you know I've taught you
before that people don't respond to what
they hear or see they respond to how
they feel when they interact with you
and one of the best ways to make
somebody feel good is that they feel
listened to and that they feel heard I
think being a great listener has lots of
benefits one people will like you more -
you're going to learn more 3 it takes
the pressure off you and so listening
skills are so critical
if you want to learn how to activate
your lying mode check the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you never get better if you're not
willing to put in the time and
basketball is very similar to the game
of life there's gonna be ups and downs
it's not always going to be easy